these have identified the two women they
say were involved in a crash that killed
two toddlers that happened in North Las
Vegas we thank you for joining us on 8
news now at 11 I'm Brian Loftis officers
say the children's aunt was behind the
wheel Under the Influence when she hit a
tree head on their mother riding in the
passenger seat this all happened near
Lone Mountain and Simmons it happened on
Sunday night Sasha Loftus spoke directly
with family tonight joins us live at the
crash site now Sasha with more
Brian this is the spot where that deadly
crash happened here in North Las Vegas
you can see a memorial is still standing
where those two girls were killed the
woman I spoke with Tonight is their
great grandmother on their father's side
she said as horrible as this is she
wants others to learn from the tragedy
they were two beautiful girls Wilma
Wilmer shares her sadness over the
sudden loss of her two
great-granddaughters they were smart
two-year-old Rose Wilmer and
three-year-old Taylor Wilmer were killed
in a violent crash Sunday night
here near Lone Mountain and Simmons in
North Las Vegas
police say 25-year-old Kalia Manning
identified as the toddler's aunt was
driving Under the Influence when she
lost control of the car and hit a tree
head-on the children's Mother 23 year
old rhonisa Washington was riding in the
passenger seat and is facing child
endangerment charges this is a call to
action
about DUI speed and proper child
restraints in a news conference earlier
this week North Las Vegas Police shared
that neither child had proper safety
restraints and says this led to Rose
being decapitated I was hoping that this
tragedy could bring light to people
about buckling up their children in
proper restraints Wilmer tells me while
her family tries to cope with this
unimaginable loss she hopes their story
can serve as a wake-up call for others
on the road don't want their death to be
in vain
now records show the child's mother was
also charged with felony domestic
battery in Henderson back in November
now as for Manning the woman who was
driving the car at the time of this
crash she faces multiple charges
including three counts of DUI resulting
in death or substantial bodily harm
reporting live in North Las Vegas
tonight Sasha Loftus 8 News Now